hi when I'm Brian Kilmeade and this is
the Fox News rundown let's talk politics
2024 GOP field I love the makeup I love
all of these men and women I mean you
see the positive Nikki Haley who's not
impressed with 37 year old Vivek Crema
Swami Tim Scott and his life story and
his comfortability on any stage Chris
Christie can argue and debate anyone in
the country at any point at any time let
alone Mike Pence does anyone doubt his
credentials and his resume and as you
look down I see Will Hurd nine years in
the CIA the governor of North Dakota I
mean this is quality stuff quality field
and they all want to do one thing they
want to supplant Donald Trump and here's
my advice to a very worthy astute crowd
stop hitting president Trump at his
strength you will never get him about
firing Anthony fauci he sidelined him
you will never get him because he didn't
do a good job immigrant with immigration
nobody worked harder tried more policies
went through more people that were
ineffective in his mind than him he even
had the controversial child separation
policy to discourage people from coming
he got Mexico to put 20 000 Marines On
the Border because he threatened tariffs
on them to the Chagrin of just about
everyone you're never going to touch him
when it comes to his strengths tax cuts
yes he's vulnerable on a few things
volatility comfortability how about
bringing people together maybe if you
think that you could spend less maybe
you feel as though you're more
presidential maybe you looked at his
four years you could point out different
ways along the way in which you would
have done a better job for the people
that supported the most this way you
could look at this situation and say I'm
a better alternative he was great at 45
I want to be the 47th president but
don't go at the president Trump on his
strengths people just shut you off you
hear that Ron DeSantis I'm Brian
Kilmeade and that's my thoughts on the
Fox News Rundown